[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to um this afternoon's
debate trust science and neutrality from
kovid to climate change we put our trust
in science and scientists
purists is meant to be neutral and
objective
yet 70 percent of all research is funded
by commercial interests and more than
half the remaining is in the pursuit of
military objectives
on the one hand we see science as the
gold standard of objective truth
yet we allow and encourage research to
be influenced in its direction by those
with powerful vested interests
can research provide an unbiased and
independent account of the world
when so much of it is burdened with
monetary incentives or should we give up
the notion that pure research can be
objective and welcome innovation whoever
is funding it and for whatever purpose
with me to debate this topic we have a
great panel three leading scientists
each with direct experience of
confronting the issues raised by the
debate tara shears is an experimental
particle physicist and one of the top
british scientists at cern
where her experiments run on the large
hadron collider the largest particle
accelerator in the world
terence keeley is a clinical biochemist
and former vice chancellor of buckingham
university and an outspoken critic of
the government funding of science
and brett weinstein is an evolutionary
biologist and visiting fellow at
princeton who came to public prominence
following his criticism of woke culture
at evergreen state college in washington
in 2017.
he's part of a group known as the
intellectual dark web and hosts the
influential dark horse podcast
i'm going to give each of them three
minutes to to set out their response to
the key question that we are seeking to
address this evening
is science unduly biased by money and
power
so tara it's all yours
thank you well let let's unpick that
question a little bit because i think
it's probably helpful to start off by
defining what we mean by science first
of all it's quite a nebulous phrase
before we then look at the issue of bias
and
and where money and power comes in
so i am going to define science as the
accumulated body of knowledge about the
physical universe and and all the life
inside it
and i'm going to define the process of
extending this knowledge as research
and our research proceeds through
something called the scientific method
whereby you form hypotheses based on
your understanding you test them by
collecting evidence and experiments you
look to see if it matches if it does
you build up your understanding you make
more predictions and so on and so on
that that's the way that
research progresses science
and that means to me that
science is a body of knowledge that's as
unbiased as we can make it and i would
argue if it's biased it's bad science
so we might want to pick up on this
later
so
science is not biased but the process of
doing it provided it's done well is not
biased either but in the introduction
you raise the issue of trust of vested
interests of financial
incentives and
well research does proceed by asking
questions and hopefully finding answers
and if somebody commissions research
they want an answer given to them and
they're quite clearly influencing the
direction that that research is taking
now does that constitute a bias on the
science i would argue not and it might
be biasing the area science is exploring
but not the science itself
but then this wider issue of who pays
for research and what they want to know
and what they're going to do with that
information and is it ethical that that
is important
and
i still don't think that bias is science
but it is an important question that we
should always ask
and that brings up the question of who
is best placed to direct the um the
direction of science should it be by a
haldane principle governed by excellence
should it be by whoever has money um who
is who is actually going to fund it and
make it happen
and you know and to what ends are they
are they asking their questions and who
is going to benefit and how are they
going to benefit when you start
overlaying all these other strategic and
financial concerns it gets really
complicated
so
my very short answer to this question
you've asked me is that no i don't think
science is biased it can't be by my
definition but those who fund it and who
commission it may be not necessarily are
but the potential for biases there
thank you tara terence
thank you i um i do actually disagree
quite a lot with tara though i think in
the end we'll agree i think the only way
you can approach a scientific paper
is to assume it's written by someone who
is very biased i think you have to
approach each individual scientific
paper the way you would approach
what a lawyer says in court
in that it is a piece of advocacy it
constitutes what someone wants you to
believe is true
you must assume
that that person is not telling any lies
i think lying is very very rare in
science but i think there are all sorts
of ways in which individuals who write
scientific papers
select the data select their
observations and such to present a case
science as a collective
i think ultimately as exactly as tara
has described it collectively moves
forward to the truth whatever that is
the way judges do about the law
but individual papers and individual
scientists believe in particular
paradigms that they're pushing and the
rule is you can't lie
but what in practice happens is that
scientists particularly in softer
sciences such as psychology
and many of the other software
scientists as opposed to the physics
of tara
select data because it's so easy to
select data and are hugely influenced by
peer review which enables them to select
the sort of data that will please either
their funders or the people who promote
them or the people who publish their
papers or the people who give them
grants and you see whole areas of
science such as nutrition for example
that collectively go wrong for decades
sometimes in the case of decades so
i agree with tara that science
collectively like the law collectively
does actually advance to truth she's
obviously right but individual
scientists should be viewed by
individual barristers
people who do not tell lies but to
absolutely present a case and only a
case and you as a as reading a
scientific paper have to be very
skeptical about each individual paper
even though you can look back on the
debates of the 19th century and agree
we've now agreed over certain
fundamental principles
thank you terence brett
oh there are interesting points of
agreement and disagreement already i
very much agree with tara that the right
way to begin is to define science so we
know what we're talking about but i
would define it differently than she
does i would say science is the method
that we use
and the surrounding context and the body
of information that accumulates in
science has to be treated differently
they can contain bias but the method
itself is immune to it in fact
although science is actually an
inefficient way of reaching answers the
reason that it has been so ascendant is
that it is the only good mechanism we
have for correcting for human bias that
is really its purpose
and so the question is how can we do
that and what happens if we place it in
a wider context of private funding
science does produce a model that
increasingly mirrors reality that is to
say predictive power goes up and the
number of assumptions we make must go
down and we get a better and better
model of reality if science is done
correctly but that very powerful process
is also fragile it does not endure
market forces well and terence is quite
right that there is a great deal of
advocacy that we see in papers in grant
applications and in committees that
decide
what to fund and therefore we have to be
aware that this process of correcting
for human bias from which we have
benefited so greatly is endangered if we
allow it to sit in a context that
corrupts it
now the discussion is somewhat fraught
because when we talk about the
possibility of public funding we are
inherently talking about
handing over the decision on what to
fund to
governments that we all recognize are
themselves corrupted so we should
separate in this the discussion of
whether ideally science must be funded
in some public way from the practical
consideration of handing those funding
decisions to governments that we have
good reason not to trust in the present
thank you all so lots of as brett was
pointing out some really interesting
points of contact and dispute here so
the underlying question i i'd like to to
address that we start off with is
can research in principle
be neutral and unbiased
um
terence
you seem to be saying that
it's never neutral that scientists are
always
advocating a point of view
yes it was einstein who said it's theory
that determines what we study
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas